you
I love to I love to ride my bicycle I
mean I ha I have had a small apartment
in New York a very small apartment and I
would say I go around my neighborhood
buy a bicycle I go to I go through the
village I go through the east village I
go to through Chinatown I'd like to go
across the bridges by bicycle I'd love
to take the beautiful Hudson River Park
bicycle way and go all the way up to to
riverside park and then to all the
opportunity to Harlem to go riding
around there to ride around the city
city college campus uptown and the I
know what is a particular place that I
like and well I like more the area that
I know more which is all the area around
the east village and the all this area
enjoy there is a lot of life and a lot
of people and the union square area